I can't stop playing Fire Emblem three
houses it asks a lot of you and each
part must be managed both individually
and as part of the whole that can be
intimidating but when it all clicks
together it really clicks each piece
feeds into the next in a rewarding loop
where you get lost in the whole
experience not just in the minutiae
[Music]
three houses casts you as a mercenary
who while out on a mission with their
father runs into a group of teens under
attack you learn that they are students
at gehrig MOC monastery where each of
them leads one of the school's three
houses black eagles blue lions or golden
deer at the behest of the church's
archbishop who definitely gives off
nefarious vibes but it is also a gentle
mom figure you end up becoming a
professor and must choose which of the
houses to lead your main role as
professor is to instruct your students
in matters of combat and prepare them
for Story battles at the end of each
month
battles in three houses feature the same
turn-based tactical combat at the heart
of the series al biet with some changes
the classic weapon triangle is
downplayed quite a bit in favour of
combat arts which have been altered
somewhat from their introduction in Fire
Emblem echoes Shadows of Valencia combat
arts are attacks tied to a weapon type
and can boost a units attack power at
the expense of weapon durability some
are effective against specific enemy
types like armored units for example is
the same complexity this series is known
for but less abstract 'add making it
easier to strategize without sacrificing
depth
that's the golden deer for you some of
the early game in optional battle maps
are open spaces that don't require you
to think too hard especially on Normal
difficulty but the story battles
throughout feature a variety of map
layouts that challenge you to consider
where your units need to be both in the
next turn and several turns down the
line many of them have different routes
enemies coming at you from multiple
angles optional treasure to chase and
other quirks that require you to split
your party up or change their equipped
classes to suit the situation this is
where things get exciting after a few
turns of cautious setup you hopefully
get to knock out tons of enemies as your
plans fall into place the depth of
strategy and these elements really
shines on Hard difficulty but especially
so when coupled with divine pulls a
limited usability divine pulse allows
you to rewind time in order to redo all
or part of the battle and it shows just
how important unit placement and attack
choice can be even a slight change can
make or break the fight it's also just a
nice quality-of-life feature if you play
on classic mode in which units who die
in battles stay dead
you might still soft reset from time to
time but it's great to be able to fix a
mistake right away
[Music]
battling of course is only one part of
life at the monastery the backbone of
three houses is the monthly school
calendar and if you like organizing
things planning ahead or school in
general this can be the most exciting
part on Sundays you have free time you
can spend in one of four ways exploring
the monastery participating inside
battles holding a seminar to improve
your student skills or simply taking the
day off
Mondays are for instruction which
consists of selecting students from a
list and choosing a few of their skills
to boost the rest of the week goes by
automatically with a sprite of the
professor running along the calendar and
stopping occasionally for random events
or Story cutscenes it sounds a bit
hands-off but there's a lot to think
about as it is and the week by week
rather than day by day structure keeps
the story and unit progression moving in
a satisfying pace the predictable
structure of each month in the fact that
you can see the full month's schedule
with events listed ahead of time gives
you the foundation to make effective
plans all that time management can
definitely be overwhelming at least at
first
you have to keep tabs on your students
skills and study goals your own skills
everyone's inventory and various other
meters and menus while planning for the
lessons and battles to come
but you're treated to a near constant
stream of positive reinforcement as
those meters fill up week by week and
your students improve their skills
you're always moving toward the next
thing the next level up the next skill
you needs to develop the next month and
what man for
witness my father
like all recent Fire Emblem games
ensuring you're invested in your units
and their relationship is the glue that
binds the whole experience together
after spending time and effort to
improve your characters strength
you're not just satisfied when they win
a fight you're proud as you work to
develop relationships with their
students and watches their friendships
grow with each other you also get to see
better results on the battlefield and
the more you invest in someone both
emotionally and through months of lesson
plans and instruction the more cautious
you'll be about putting them in harm's
way and the more you'll work to come up
with a solid battle strategy as you
unlock new support levels with different
characters you get cut scenes that flush
out the students and faculty more for
the most part each support conversation
is just a piece of who a character is
and as you slowly build support levels
over time you begin to uncover the full
picture of each person as a result
learning more about each of the
characters and their place in the
monastery is as much a reward for
progress as the level bars that take
forever upward as you go okay
I confess I am scared of ghosts the
monastery is unnerving to me at night
every NPC is fully voiced in both
English and Japanese which brings a lot
of life to the brief support
conversations disappointingly though the
professor is silent they aren't voiced
and they don't even have subtitled
dialogue during conversations characters
do however refer to the professor's
personality and how they come across
throughout the game which is odd
considering they mostly nod at things
this puts distance between you and the
characters you're bonding with and it's
a missed opportunity in a game where the
protagonist hasn't otherwise set look
personality and backstory it's not hard
to like a lot of the characters though
they draw you in with anime archetypes
like the ladies man the bratty prints
and the clumsy but well-meaning girl and
surprised you with much more nuance
under the surface you might discover a
character you thought was a jerk is
actually one of your favorites or slowly
stop using a less than favorite
character in battle since you're so
insistent upon telling me what my face
should be doing perhaps my blade can
restructure your face with a more
permanent smile each houses campaign
feels distinct but not so different that
one seems way better than the other
every house has a mix of personalities
and skills and they all have their own
advantages and disadvantages students
from different houses can form
friendships with each other too and you
can eventually recruit students from
other houses to join yours
than being repetitive on a second play
three recruiting gives you access to
different relationship combinations you
can see a different side to a character
through a different set of support
conversations and while the overall
setup if the game is largely the same
across the three houses each has its own
web of B plots and the second half of
the game will look very different
depending on who you're with and the
choices you've made the first half
concerns the church its secrets and the
fact that the professor knows very
little about their own identity as the
basic loop of each month pulls you
forward so too does the promise of
learning the truth about something
whether it's why the archbishop wanted
you to be a teacher in the first place
or who a suspicious masked individual is
after a five-year time scape you enter
the war phase of the game while the
structure is the same and you even
instruct your units since you still need
to train for battle the focus shifts to
how specific stories they involve a lot
of hard decisions with old friends
becoming enemies people you wish you
didn't have to kill and students who've
changed either in spite of or because of
your guidance late game battles are
especially challenging with higher
stakes and multi Lane layouts that
require a lot of forethought success in
these battles is incredibly rewarding as
you're seeing dozens of hours of
investment in your students reach a
crescendo but they're bittersweet in
context
you were wide open when all was said and
done all I could think about was
starting another playthrough I was
curious about the mysteries left
unsolved of course but I also hope to
undo my mistakes
there were characters I didn't talk to
enough students I didn't recruit and far
more effective ways to train my units a
second playthrough treads familiar
ground in the beginning but after
learning and growing so much in the
first it feels fresh too that speaks to
three houses mechanical complexity in
depth as well as the connections it
fosters with its characters and whether
you're managing inventories or battle
fields it's the kind of game that's hard
to put down even when it's over
reach for my hand Essaouira way